I have faith that one has been brought
into this world for reasons none of us
would claim to understand them but we
don't and we have faith about various
theories about how we came here but that
somehow we're lucky to be here and for
however long we are and while we're here
it makes having a good sense to try on
your infinitely small way to make this
world a somewhat different place in a
somewhat different better place and it
would have been without you and that
involves helping the society it involves
helping people involves a lot of things
that involved with making the world a
little bit better in your own small way
now some people might call that faith
you know why do you believe that is it
because you're gonna go to heaven or or
is it because it just makes very good
sense to be a good productive
empathetic sympathetic human being
helpful